Let me go next to Cooper from Texas.
Cooper from Texas.
Tell me what's going on there.
Holy crap.
David were purple.
You guys I know, yep, her Texas is in play.
That's amazing.
You know, I'm not very old, but from my parents
and even my grandfather, grandmother never
would've thought that Texas would be in the
state it's in right now.
Now, I think we want to be realistic.
You know, it's not if if Biden.
I think Biden does not win Texas in the end.
But the fact that it's this close is incredible.
And you know what?
Maybe he will win and it'll be a historic.
But we just don't know yet.
But everybody has to vote.
I really wanted to ask you to remember in
your last video, you remarked to some extent
that you said you're more for expanding the
court now than you've ever been.
Yes, I do.
Could you expand on that some more?
Because I'm I'm very on the fence about something
like that.
Okay.
So I did a segment earlier this week on it
which has not yet, which is is on YouTube
by the time this call goes live.
It will be on YouTube.
But you've obviously not seen it yet.
One of the main arguments against expanding
the court from the right is that it's somehow
oppressive, undemocratic, unconstitutional.
The reality is, despite losing the popular
vote in six of the last seven presidential
elections, Republicans have selected the overwhelming
majority of recent picks to the court.
That's not Democratic.
Number two, many presidents have added or
reduced seats on the Supreme Court.
So it's not a historical.
And number three, there's this slippery slope
argument that if Biden adds some seats, the
next president with that will add seats, the
next president will add seats, the next president
will will add seats.
The reality is you need the White House, the
House and the Senate to do it.
That in itself reduces the opportunity for
it to happen.
And I don't believe the public would accept
expanding the Supreme Court indefinitely.
I believe in 2021, if Joe Biden wins and Democrats
take the Senate, the public will understand
the travesty that has happened over the last
four years and they will be okay with expanding
the court.
I don't buy the slippery slope argument.
So I am now very strongly for it.
And then just one last thing.
I'll give it a give up the airtime.
What do you think the chances are of another
Trump electoral victory if if he were to,
let's say, cut Biden's leads across the board
by like three points, something insane like
that.
If Biden's lead drops by three by Election
Day, I think Trump's shot at an electoral
victory becomes effectively 50/50.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
Great to hear from you.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding on to talk to me, don't
hang up, because we are going right back to
the phones after this short break.
The David Pakman
Show David Pakman dot.com.